it's critical to know where sensitive
data is but that can be difficult in
complex systems at Google we encrypt our
customers data in different ways
depending upon what the data is doing
and all of this happens by default with
no user action required data is
potentially vulnerable to unauthorized
access as it travels across the internet
or within networks because it's linked
to most ISPs in the world
Google's private global network helps to
improve the security of data in transit
by limiting the hops across the public
Internet any data traveling from a
customer's device to Google's cloud is
protected using HTTPS or TLS limiting
opportunities for traffic to be
intercepted in fact Google is the first
major cloud provider to enable this by
default at Google we encrypt our
customers data in different ways
depending upon what the data is doing
whether it is stored in a database or in
transit to and from Google it all
happens by default with no user action
required data is encrypted at the
hardware layer inside of our data center
that way it can only be decrypted in our
cloud on another verified Google machine
when it's stored data is broken up into
numerous different shards and sent to
different servers this guards against
hackers and it's good for disaster
recovery and business continuity
ensuring against natural disasters
unplanned downtime or equipment failures
when you call up a document in Google
Drive for example the document is
recalled from all of its storage points
decrypted and reassembled in the blink
of an eye additionally as customers you
have the option of managing encryption
keys with our cloud key management
service or even supplying your own
encryption keys if you're looking for
additional granular levels of control
data loss prevention is an effective
technology to ensure that sensitive data
doesn't leave the organization or get
accessed by people that it's not
intended for in Google cloud platform
and G suite users can find and secure
sensitive content minimize what data
they collect and implement data
governance policies our DLP API helps
you to manage and run analytics on your
cloud data without introducing
additional risk to your organization it
provides fast scalable classification
and optional redaction for over 40
sensitive data types like credit card
numbers names passport numbers and more
as you can see here it can be used to
automatically classify or redact
sensitive data from a text stream before
you write it to disk generate logs or
perform analysis on it to find out more
about how Google cloud can help protect
you from major cyber threats contact us
at google.com slash cloud slash security